こんにちは
あ前社長です談合 k
コメント見たらまずほら前はだのテーブルで撮っているときだったんじゃないですか
あの時が入っていけんとがこの出雲
最近とってだろうスタンスだとからなぁ
遠すぎるという声があったんでこの
ふうに
一眼レフをうまく利用したこの
思う
カメラスタンスで取ろうと思うんですけどどうですか
いやだありがとうございますこのカメラしたんですかあのいつものちょっと透明の
スタンス
を奪はもう
取っ払ったんでもう無理このカメラがあればいつもの肉はちょっと
アンケートしたいんでぜひコメントしてください
通常に高評価してください前にチャンネル登録してください銭友達に広めてください
普通あの
わかりますか
ローサウンド
濃厚たまごのずう新フレンチトーストです
いただきますよ
といっ
うんしっかり仕上げました135円です
日キーのシールが付いてます墓地ローズの定員なんですよ
なんかたぶんコンビニについロードについてもう1年近くやってるからプロ村について
はもう神レベルまで達してるんで
尾長ローソンで困ったら全部聞いてください
加えられなかったら
ごめんなさいなんていたら卵とバターの味がすごいいい
なんか濃いんですよ
卵好きな人とか
こっちのばまぁあのー県とた目で見てください
ぎろいそうな魔法が進み混んでるんだよ
うん
うまい
なんかねえ
本当にこれは
もう一のたまに紹介ふざけるんだけど本当にお勧めします
絶対
今年中にんいやもうそんなんでもないですけど
絶対食べた方がいいですよ僕が選べ
両村のファンナンバーは絶対ベンツ闘争と思います
けど卵嫌いな人食ったら使えなく
テレビ映像ですがこの画質低下この画像の感じ
コメントまってますんで
宜しくお願いします
じゃあバイトいってきますいやがああああああっ
ni